I'm Justin Feld. I'm a scout master with Troop 89 in Downersgrove, Illinois.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks for everything you do, Clark. And now see you. scout master
Jake and Dave are going on a scout camping trip and they get their tents set up.
and Dave's kind of new to all this. and he looks at Jake and he says, well,
I guess the tents all set up and we can get in. he says no, no, no. Jake says no,
we still need to put the ground cloth in the tent. and Dave looks around and he
sees that there is another piece in the tent bag and he says, oh, this one here.
and Jake says, yep, yep, that's the one. and Dave says, well, I can take care of that.
where's the grinder?
okay, go back and listen to it again if you have to.
hey, this is podcast number 273.
well, welcome back to the scout master podcast. this is Clark Green. let's take
a look in the mailbag. oh, there's one message in the mailbag this week from
Beth Ann Kim. Now, a while back, Beth Ann got in touch with me
and she asked me to help her get some answers to a couple of questions for
her, because she's working on a project for
Scouting University involving CubPacks, and so I talked about this a couple of
podcasts ago and posted a survey on the site, and
Beth Ann wrote in to say thanks. it helped with my project immensely.
I've received about 50 plus answers so far. by far the biggest problem in
CubScoutPacks is, unsurprisingly, having one person do too much,
and the variety of responses and ways it was stated
is very helpful because it shows how many ways this can end up happening.
the other common answer was: having one family in too many positions is a
problem as well. I hope you and your scouts have a
great time at summer camp. well, Beth Ann, thank you. I hope
you have a great summer too, and you know, hey, it's June.
people are either off to summer camp or getting ready to go to summer camp
or recovering from summer camp at this point, so things are a little quieter,
but Beth Ann's survey got me thinking about a couple of things
that I want to share with you a little bit later on in this podcast.
before I do, though, we had one live chat session. this past week
turned out to be a pretty busy week for me personally, and then
our power was out for about almost 36 hours here,
so I had a bit of a break from working on the blog and the podcast and
things. but in addition to the frequent flyers that show up at our chat
sessions, we also heard from Andrew Rimes, who's a
chartering organization representative in Moreno Valley, California.
I post when the chat is live through the twitter feed and the facebook feed.
keep an eye on those. come to scoutmastercgcom, sign in
and join us on these live chats. everything- the live chats, the blog, the
podcast, all the stuff that we're doing- is here to help
scouters, and I'm honored to hear from scouters all
over the world who say that they do find it helpful.
I depend on people like you to help me keep this all freely available, and the
way this works is we have a backer program.
it's an unusual idea, so give me just a moment to explain it.
if I was sending out a paper magazine or a newsletter,
you'd expect there to be costs associated with that right. I'd need to
pay printers and writers and postage and all that stuff.
now what we're doing is really actually pretty similar. somebody spends their
time producing the content that we publish
and encourage the expenses of publishing it. I want to keep it freely
available for everybody to do that. some of you who are
listening and subscribe to the emails that I send out
and read the blog, become backers, and you become a backer by making a one
time kind of voluntary subscription payment, and that payment helps me cover
the expenses of producing and publishing what you find on
scoutmastercgcom, including what you're listening to right now.
here's what I need you to do this week: go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page and you'll find a number of
options that will make you a scoutmastercgcom
backer. so go and become a backer this week and I'll make sure to thank you
personally in our next podcast. I want to talk a little bit about some
thoughts that came to me as I was reading the responses
to Beth Ann's survey that I mentioned earlier,
and I have one very brief email question to answer and that's going to take up
the remainder of the podcast. so let's get started. shall we scout
master ship in seven minutes or less?
so I mentioned earlier- uh, in an email from Beth Ann Kim,
the cub pack survey that we did over the past week or so,
and you'll remember that Beth Ann told us that by far
the biggest problem was, unsurprisingly, having one person
do too much and not delegate their responsibilities.
and there was another common answer, which was having one family
do too much. you know, having a husband and wife
be the cub master and the committee chair, for instance.
that people keep mentioning those two things in this survey
indicate to me they're pretty common problems and my experience corresponds to
that. you know, I've seen that happen before
and I want to spend a little time today talking about
how I would fix those problems if I were king.
I'm not king, I'm not going to be king anytime soon,
but just by way of observation and maybe encouraging some thinking about this
and maybe even people acting on this advice. you know,
here's what I think. I think that the organizational structure that we apply
to the different age divisions in scouting- and when I talk about age
divisions so we're talking about the big age divisions- are
the cub pack, the scout troop and the venturing crew-
correct, and within the cub pack there are other age divisions.
you have tigers, wolves, bears and weeblos. so the organizational structure that
we employ, that divides those age divisions up into
separate units administered by separate committees,
ends up creating, I think, a kind of perpetual emergency for cub packs
and that perpetual emergency colors. what happens
in the other two age divisions and the source of that perpetual emergency in
cub packs is the fact that we encourage
scouters to follow their children up through the various age divisions and
that creates this vacuum in the youngest age divisions
where we're continuously scrambling for volunteers,
and leaves the least experienced folks at the youngest age divisions.
to my mind, the families and the cubs in those early age divisions
would really benefit from somebody who has a lot of experience with scouting.
imagine what would happen in our school system if we had teachers
follow one group of students all the way from kindergarten
up through their phd program. that would mean that every time we have a
kindergarten class we have a brand new teacher
and we'd never give that teacher the opportunity to get good
at teaching kindergarten because the next year we'd move them on to the first
grade and then they wouldn't get very good at
teaching first grade because we'd move them on to
second grade the next year and so on and so forth. now, if you think about it,
that is the expectation that our organizational structure creates for
our volunteers. you know you end up volunteering at whatever
part of the program you end up volunteering for and then follow
your son on up through the various age divisions.
and because of that it's really kind of uncommon
to find a volunteer working with a cub pack
who has much more than five or six years experience with cubs.
and if they have five or six years experience with cubs
it's never in the same position. they've probably changed at least twice and
many of them three or four times, not all. but many of the
scouts who do have a long tenure in cubs are get kind of worn out
because they have to plan and present the program
and scramble to qualify and train new key volunteers
to replace the ones that they lose every year because
those experienced volunteers move on into a scout troop.
now things have been this way for ages and ages and we just think it's
normal and maybe we don't sit back and look at it.
but I think you'd agree with me that it's kind of
nutty, you know, I mean, and it creates a lot of difficulties.
and what got me thinking about this was finding out
most other scouting organizations use a very different structure
for age divisions. rather than having distinct, separate units for cubs and
troops and crews, they have what they call a scout group
that administers all the age divisions, so their packs, troops and crews
aren't separate and walled off and have their own committees, and
really a lot of duplicative effort. when you look at it, they're all in one big
group. now that doesn't mean that all the age
divisions meet together at the same time and share all the same
volunteers. no, you have specialists in each one
but that. but you have a group committee and group leadership
that helps ease the transitions between the age divisions
and share the experience of all of the volunteers between the age divisions.
now going back to the answers: in this survey
one person doing way too much was a very common answer
as to a mistake that cub packs make with our organizational structure,
creating this deficit at the lower age divisions.
that means that the most experienced person in the cub scout pack-
let's say that's the cub master or the committee chair-
and the demands of the program- keeping things moving right, making sure things
are planned and making sure things are happening
well- that's always going to take first priority. so
involving new people takes a bit of a back seat to that
and it takes a lot of energy and that's when the cub master or the committee
chair ends up taken on way too many responsibilities,
because you know they sit there and they think,
look, i if i could get somebody to do this, but it's going to be harder
to get a new person, get them trained, get the paperwork filled out,
get them involved, then it is for me just to do this myself, and it makes
perfectly good sense and, been there, done that.
i have several scars that i could show you. so i don't want to
in any way fault the people who end up in that position. okay,
because we create that with our organizational structure. it's not
their fault. now some folks in cub packs hit on
what they consider to be a good answer- and that was reflected in the survey results
too- and they began involving more and more people, and that's almost always the
parents of the cubs. the parents that they're
involving may know a lot about scouting and they may not, usually
not a whole lot right, and they do their best and they have hearts of gold,
but they often end up causing more problems
than they solve and as this is happening, the most experienced scouts are getting
ready to abandon them, you know, to move on and that's
handing the new folks even more responsibility and the whole
cycle kind of begins again. so if you're listening to me
and you're an overburdened cub scout volunteer,
it's not really that you're doing something wrong or you've failed.
it's that i think. at least the organizational structure has kind of
failed you. there are a couple of other things that happen too
because of this structure. it complicates the transitions between age divisions
and we have two major transitions. we should have three major
transitions, but that's another story because we don't really have a
transition point where scouts become venturers.
that's all really muddled. we'll talk about that some other time.
the two major transition points that we have
that i want to talk about right now are tigers to wolves
and we belongs to scouts, and it's very difficult
to keep track of the numbers here because they aren't often published,
certainly not on a national basis, and we may not really be paying very close
attention to them on a local basis. if you've been around for a while, we
all know that we lose a pretty shocking percentage
of scouts between tiger, cubs and wolves and between weeblos and scouts.
now some of that loss is definitely accounted for in the developmental cycle
that our scouts are going through during those years
from weeblos to scouts. usually they're transitioning out of
an elementary school into a middle school or an intermediate school
situation and that transition and what's happening
to children that age anyway, is going to be a factor in whether they stay in
scouts or not. but i think there's a percentage
of the attrition that we see there that definitely
are owing to this organizational structure. when we're talking about the
transition between tigers and wolves, i think the problem
there often is the kind of difficult cycle we have
with tiger den leaders, and that is because
who ends up being the tiger den leader? most of the time,
in my experience, most of the time it's a brand new
volunteer right, and you know what a tiger den.
that's pretty intense. that's some very intense time
kind of overlay with that intensity, the fact that you have
your child involved in it, it's really kind of amazing, isn't it, that people
actually survive. but generally we have our least
experienced volunteers in that role trying to figure things out, trying to
present a program and deal with boys that age
at the same time. that's a lot of that's some pretty heavy lifting
and in my experience at least, i know there's going to be exceptions to this,
but in my experience at least, people do one year of tigers and they are
done. man, they want to move on and a lot of that is
because they've had a reasonably pleasant experience doing it. but
they've also been really challenged because this is all brand new-
let's keep talking about this new tiger den leader for a moment.
so we bring this person on, we get them to volunteer, we get them training
and the training for them is going to be very
focused on what they need to do to work with their tiger cub den.
it's not necessarily going to give them a very good overview of scouting and
the older divisions and how this all works together and how it's all
connected. so it's perfectly understandable
that, because they are focused on the program that they need to present
right away, most cub volunteers don't have
a good understanding of the continuity of the program.
very few, if any of the other adult volunteers in the pack that they're
working with have this overview, because
they're all really focused on what needs to happen next.
and as people begin to understand the continuity of the program, well, what do we
do? we move them out of the pack so
that experience is lost, because now we wall them off into
a separate troop somewhere and because of our organizational
structure- troops and packs- you know, some of them are very well
connected and some of them work well together and
do things together, but that is the exception to the rule.
so in the cub pack generally- and i'm just trying to
observe and be objective here, and if you're a cub scout
volunteer, don't think that i'm talking down to you or
or saying that you're not a good person or anything like that. okay,
this is just observational. so what we end up with in cub scouts is our
least experienced volunteers where they're working with their own children-
more about that in a moment- who don't have a really good
understanding of the full continuity of the program because
they don't often get to work with volunteers at the troop in the crew
level. and this creates that kind of perpetual volunteer
emergency at the cub scout level and it
really complicates the two important transitions that i talked about.
and this kind of stratification of our volunteers right
follows into the scout troop and the venturing crew
and it stratifies our effort because we have different ideas of what's
important right now. those ideas usually correspond
to what our sons need at the time. this stratification
happens in troops all the time because scouters with younger
boys involved with the troop write to me and say: look, you know, this whole
troop is all about the older guys. they're all working on eagle
and our younger guys are kind of like left out in the cold and they don't
got a whole lot of attention. and the older scouters write to me and say:
the volunteers that came up out of the cub scout pack
are want to do a third year of weeblos and we're having a real problem
getting them to transition into the troop. so this stratification of of focus
comes along with the idea of parents following their
boys up through the different age divisions.
and i've got to tell you once again: cub scout friends, you know i love you,
right, most of the adults over time who have left the cub scout pack
moved on into the troop, become committee members or assistant scout masters
or taking on one or other position of responsibility with the troop.
they kind of get out of the cub scout pack. they wipe their brow-
that was hard- and they find out that the scout troop
is a lot easier on adults most of the time. okay, so we've described all the
difficulties that are caused by our present organizational system.
so let's take a quick look at what the possibilities are
and what the rest of the world uses and that is the group concept.
it eliminates a lot of the difficulties i've been talking about.
if we had cub scout packs, boy scout troops and venturing crews
working very closely together, all under the same steering committee
with their separate subcommittees to take care of their separate concerns,
with volunteers dedicated to the various roles involved in the age divisions
that had the benefit of each other's experiences,
we wouldn't be continuously scrambling to fill positions at the cub level
and we'd ease the transition points and we'd eliminate this kind of stratification
of interest on the part of a lot of our volunteers.
in scout organizations that use this group concept
you can end up having people who are the corollary
of tiger den leaders doing that for 8, 10 or 12 years
because that's where their skill set is, that's what they're most interested in.
they don't feel like they have to follow their children
through the age divisions because their children are not getting separated
from them by going off into another group
somewhere. they're all part of the same group. the folks in the cub
age divisions know the folks in the scout age divisions who know the folks in the
venturing age divisions, because they're all part of the same group.
and when we do bring in a new volunteer. rather than putting them
in one of the most intense situations, right
like being a tiger cub den leader, we can kind of
ease them in and they have the benefit of a much larger group of volunteers
who will help them and support them, make things work for them.
I would think we would want our most experienced
scouts working with our youngest ages and their families,
helping them understand and contextualize the way scouting works.
I mean, being a tiger den leader is an intense experience
because boys that age pretty intense to work with
families that age pretty intense. but it would be reasonably
light lifting for me- and it's not because I'm anything special,
I just have a lot of experience. I think as a tiger den leader I could help
parents get involved without frightening them away by asking too much,
and I'd be able to give both the tigers and their families
some context about how scouting works and what will happen
in the coming years and I'd have some objectivity
that a parent being a den leader would not have.
not because they're bad people, it, they just wouldn't have it because they
have a child involved. so anyway, I don't know what you want to call
that, maybe a rant. I hope I wasn't too ranty
because I think it's a pretty valuable idea. it's not my own
by any means. I mean it's just the way the rest of the world
organizes scouting in groups rather than separate units like we have.
and when you look at you know what are kind of the perennial difficulties
that we have in our different age divisions
and you look at the group concept, is that group concept
would certainly mitigate, if not eliminate, a lot of these difficulties if we
adopted it in the right way. so just food for thought.
and, uh, I really like to hear you, I think I'd really like to hear your
reaction to the to that idea.
me
email, that is. folks, and here's an answer to one of
your emails.
this question came in since the last podcast. somebody told me that the whole
thing with the weeblows transition is changing,
uh, and that weeblows are only supposed to visit one
troop. can you tell me whether this is true or not?
aha, well, that really doesn't sound right, does it?
that would be a pretty big change. so we know that
there are often a lot of rumors floating around and mishap
apprehensions about what's happening and things that seem to take on a life of
their own. so here's a very simple approach that you might
find useful. this is the one that I use whenever somebody tells me something
that they represent as being a bsa policy,
for instance. you know the thing? things are going to change and weeblows are only
going to get to visit one troop. I asked them to show me the resource
that explains that policy in writing. now, if they can't show me where it's written,
then I kind of have my answer: it's a rumor, it's an urban legend of
scouting. okay, there have always been, and likely
will always be, folks who play whisper down the lane with things like this,
and about eight times out of 10 if it doesn't sound right,
then someone simply got the wrong end of the stick.
so my very simple advice to you: when you hear something that doesn't really
sound quite right, ask whoever is telling you
to show you where it's written, and if they can't,
well, then you have your answer, don't you? hey, you can get in touch with me
with your questions and ideas, and it's pretty easy to do,
and I'm going to tell you how to do that in just a moment.
thanks for listening to this 273rd edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
you can keep in touch by going to scoutmastercgcom
and you can read over 1700 different blog posts on
on various scouting subjects. another good way to keep in touch is through the
vast panorama of social media. you can join the 9300 folks who
like scoutmaster blog on facebook. tweet, along with the chorus of 1200 or so
tweeters on twitter. pin the paltitudinous pictures proffered
publicly with 2000 other prolific printers on pinterest.
hey, we occasionally post a video to youtube too,
and you can join the 400 odd folks who form the exclusive
yet very quiet scoutmaster cg circle on google plus.
now, if that social media stuff is just not your daily wake, if you can't face
facebook, if twitter makes you bitter, if you've no
interest in pinterest, if you don't put the? u in youtube,
if you're a minus when it comes to google plus, don't worry about it, monkey.
zoom in to the late 90s and fire off an email. now, remember, you'll need the
computer because the typewriter won't work for email,
and you can aim your electronic communications
to clark at scoutmastercgcom. that's c, l, a, r, k, e. at scoutmastercgcom.
it only remains for me to repeat yet again: the scoutmaster blog and the
scoutmaster podcast and all the other things that we do
are not in any way official publications of the boy scouts of america or any
other scouting organization. they are not endorsed or
sponsored by any other scouting organization.
it is only me. that's right. i have a microphone and a laptop and an
internet connection and several thousand people bother to listen to my
podcast. beyond that, oh well
it's. it's all about helping our fellow scouters
and having a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, sir robert baton. pal sir robert.
good luck to you and good happy. why? thank you, sir?
until next time everyone.